أجنبي
شعر الناس في المنطقة أن أه
تعلمون أن هناك علاقة بين
الولايات المتحدة والبلدان التي
زرتها ، وهذا أمر مهم جدًا لزوجي
وأعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا
عندما أذهب أن أقوم بتكوين علاقة People to
People وليس  من حكومة إلى
حكومة ، وأتمنى أن
تصبح بعد ذلك مع الأشخاص الذين ألتقي بهم ، وآمل أن تصبح
بعد ذلك من القلب إلى القلب ،
شكرًا لك [
موسيقى] أجنبية ،
حسنًا ، أعتقد أنك تعرف أن أحد
أسباب ذهابي هو إلقاء نظرة على
البرامج التعليمية التي أزورها للمدارس  طوال الوقت الذي كنت فيه
مدرسًا لمدة 38 عامًا ،
وأعتقد أن تلك المهارات
التي طورتها هي تلك المهارات التي طورتها أنت تعرفها تمامًا
كمدرس وتتعلق بالشباب في الغالب
وأحب أن أرى
وجوههم عندما  حسنًا ، لقد رأيت ذلك ، فأنت تعلم
متى كان الأطفال الذين طوروا
برامجهم الخاصة ومدى شعورهم بالفخر
لأنفسهم وبالأطفال الذين طوروا
الروبوت والروبوتات والأطفال الذين
كانوا يقومون بالبرمجة وتعلم اللغة الإنجليزية
بغض النظر عما كانوا يفعلونه.
استمع إلى قصصهم لمعرفة ما
يتعلمونه ولأن التعليم
مهم جدًا في كل بلد في
العالم لأن التعليم أعتقد أنه يعني
التمكين الاقتصادي في تلك البلدان
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا
أجنبيًا